your favorite  video  I don't like anyone's been more and I  didn't get to explore the island as much  so this time first place that I went to  in Waimea clan this place is seriously  so awesome look at this it's crazy the  largest it's ten miles long one mile  wide that's pretty crazy  and then there's part of the island  called the Napali coast to actually  dance right you see me there a pipe or  get on a boat  the show was not about to hike there hey  hi I'm on a boat I just took a boat tour  around the pali coast of hawaii is  seriously so wonderful cuz our captain  captain trent snorkeling right now like  all these we put it oh wait where they  go  notice things but I wanted to talk about  this video thanks for watching and don't  forget to leave a comment of the place  that you most want to visit and I'll be  reading those and I'll see you guys  later